If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears,
then you will also appear with him in glory.
Well, good morning church family.
It's always great to be together in a spirit of worship like this. Uh,
if you're new with us, my name is John. I'm one of the pastors here.
I would love to get to meet you if I haven't yet. Please come say hello to us.
Uh, there's ways you can do that out in the lobby as well or right up here
afterwards. Um, as always, it's an honor to get to open God's word with you. If,
uh, you are new, you may not know.
We just started a series of sermons through the Apostle Paul's letter to the
Colossian Christians in the New Testament. And so we're just getting into that,
being reminded of this truth.
You see it everywhere on the logos that Christ is above all.
Plus, last week you saw, uh,
some things about the book that maybe help us understand as we go into it. Uh,
the many false beliefs that that church that was young in Colossae was facing
was, was assaulting that church.
And so Paul felt it was important for him to write this letter to defend the
gospel. What is the gospel actually in itself,
but then what does it mean and implications for it?
And we saw last week really how our context today is not that much different
from what it was 2000 years ago in Colossae.
And so this speaks to us just as much as it did to them.
And so go ahead and take your copy of God's word. Turn with me to Colossians.
It's most of the way towards the end.
It's a little bit after a couple long books. Romans one, two Corinthians,
Colossians. Just put a bookmark there. Again,
you've got some ways to do that out in the lobby. Uh,
that would magnets or phone lock screens, whatever.
But put a bookmark there and we'll come back to it over the next few weeks.
Of course, before we get there though,
one of my favorite days of the year is Thanksgiving. Anybody else love?
Thanksgiving is your favorite day. Uh,
I'll always with family and football's on all day.
Of course I always eat way too much pumpkin pie. Well, I should say, uh,
whipped cream with a little bit of pumpkin pie. Let's say it that way. Uh,
it just, it's sweet time together, of course.
But one of the funny moments to me in nearly every Thanksgiving I'm at is the
mixed reaction around the table whenever we are are,
are sitting down and we're just about to get ready to eat.
And then someone says,
let's all go around the table and say what we're thankful for. Right?
You know what I'm talking about, right? I am not throwing stones at that.
It's just fine. Keep doing it. But,
but it's just so funny the reactions you get. Some people are groaning,
some people are chuckling. Uh,
some people get these wide eyes like they don't wanna say anything. Uh,
all of these reactions are different. Some people treat it like a joke, right?
Just say, I'm so thankful for my family and they look around at everybody just,
it's not really serious in that. But,
but think about that moment again. I get it. It's fine.
But is that true gratitude, right? Is that really what Thanksgiving,
not just the day, but Thanksgiving in general. Is that really what that's about?
Is it valid if we have to force it to say thank you for things?
Well, today we're gonna see what true thanksgiving really is all about,
where it comes from, plus what it leads to.
And we're just gonna be a few verses now into the book of Colossians verses
three through eight of chapter one. You'll see it here.
We always thank God the father of our Lord Jesus Christ.
When we pray for you, since we heard of your faith in Christ Jesus,
of the love that you have for all the saints,
because of the hope laid up for you in heaven of this,
you have heard before in the word of the truth, the gospel,
which has come to you as indeed in the whole world,
that is bearing fruit and increasing as it also does among you,
since the day you heard it and understood the grace of God in truth,
just as you learned it from a paths our beloved fellow servant,
he's a faithful minister of Christ on your behalf and is made known to us.
Your love in the Spirit. God,
help us to see today what you want us to see. Open our eyes, our hearts,
our lives for your change to happen.
That we would not be merely hearers of the word,
but we would be doers of it in your power,
for your glory in Jesus authority we pray. Amen.
So again, this,
this was typical of the Apostle Paul when he would write letters after
introducing himself.
He would include this section of Thanksgiving for his readers.
But it was actually more than just saying, Hey, thanks for being who you are.
And almost every one of his letters recorded here in the New Testament.
This Thanksgiving section gives the theological basis for the rest of the
letter. It's the foundation. It's about what God had done for them.
And that's what then gave him the ability to say what he said later.
And so Paul's Thanksgiving was not just to puff them up like,
like here's how great you are. Here's how awesome you are.
It's actually reminding them again of the glory of Christ and what he had
done for them. It's,
it's a reminder before he gets too far into it that his salvation was
great. And in reality,
that should be the source of our Thanksgiving giving.
God himself should be the source of Thanksgiving.
God is our source.
We're gonna see this a lot more next week whenever we look at starting in verse
nine, what Paul prays for the people, actually his prayer for them.
But notice again in verse three, he writes this. He says,
we always thank God the father of our Lord Jesus Christ when we pray for you.
So he's regularly praying for them and he's thanking God for them,
thanking God for what he's done.
But notice the theological statement Paul's making here.
He's not just praying to some generic God out there.
He's not even just praying to the,
the Jewish God that he had been praying to for his most of his life until
a couple years ago. No,
he's praying to this God known as the Father of the one who used
to see as an imposter, Jesus Christ,
the one that he was persecuting trying to squash out.
Now he sees God Yahweh as the Father of Lord Jesus Christ.
And notice it wasn't just a generic Jesus either the Lord Jesus Christ,
like the fullest term you could use for who Jesus was.
But this was who Paul and the church saw Jesus to be, right?
They saw Jesus as God himself.
'cause remember that was counter to whatever other gods were around them.
In Colossae,
they were hearing all these other things that this could be a God and this could
be a God and there could be a lot of gods. And he says, no, Jesus is God.
But that, remember, that was the source of thanksgiving for Paul.
That anything good in our lives comes from God Almighty.
It comes from the Lord of heaven and earth. The sovereign one, the good one,
the holy one. What we just sang about, it comes from him.
That's the source of our Thanksgiving.
So everything he's about to say about the Colossians to the Colossians,
everything else in this letter, all about them, all about the gospel,
it's all sourced from God.
That's the foundation of everything. And that's a good reminder for us today,
isn't it? See, we cannot,
especially in a, a very blessed wealthy area,
we cannot divorce God's blessings from the source.
And we tend to love what we have instead of remembering where we get it from.
Everything. Even our breath comes from him.
As James one 17 says,
every good and perfect gift is from above coming down from the father of lights.
So you think about that Thanksgiving table,
of course you won't be excited to share what you're thankful for.
If you don't truly see God as the giver of all good things in your life,
if you just assume you have, everything's good, I've got it because I am good,
you're not gonna be grateful. Paul is grateful here.
The source of his thanksgiving is God himself.
But then he continues and he shows the Colossians.
The foundation of thanksgiving then is hope.
Everything good comes from God.
But then the the basis for it is hope.
Look again at verses four and five,
since we heard of your faith in Christ Jesus and of the love that you have for
all the saints because of the hope laid up for you in
heaven. Now,
the construction here in the original language is a little backwards to us.
The way Greek was written is different than the way English works.
And so it can get a little confusing to us. It reads a little funny to us.
But notice the first word of verse four is the word sense,
S I N c E. That word ties it back to what he just said,
right? So he says something, he says sense. So there,
there's a connection between those two things that the reason,
so notice this.
The reason he thinks God when he prays for them is because he'd heard about
their faith and their love, that they were full of faith, full of love.
He's like, man, thank you God for that.
But further he sees the reason they have that faith in love
in verse five is because of the hope laid up for them in heaven.
See that He's thanking for what he sees,
but then he ties it to the foundation, which is their hope.
That's why he gives thanks. Now this word for hope,
we use that word all the time. Like I hope the cowboys win.
Probably not going to, but like I hope, I hope, I hope there's like this,
this idea of this state or activity of longing that we're we're expectant
for something, right?
But here the word actually refers to the thing hoped for
four. Here it's,
it's this thing laid up for them in heaven,
that something is stored there for them later.
Like that squirrel in your backyard, you know,
digging holes and putting acorns in there that that's the hope.
Not that he hopes it's still there,
but it's the actual hope itself in the ground.
Something stored up for us is the hope. Yes,
there's expectancy for that of course,
but it's more about the tangible item.
And so when Paul writes this here in Colossians one,
he's talking about this hope laid up for them in heaven is this perfect eternity
in the new creation with Jesus.
Like this is the hope that you have laid up,
stored up for you in heaven is this reality.
You get to be with him forever in perfection.
Not just that you long for it, look forward to it,
but it actually is something to hold onto.
I love how one Peter one verses three through five says it,
it ties hope to that future. It says,
blessed be the God and Father of our Lord Jesus Christ,
according to his great mercy,
he's caused us to be born again to a living hope through the
resurrection of Jesus Christ from the dead.
Not just that notice to an inheritance that is imperishable,
undefiled, unfading kept in heaven for you.
Who by God's power are being guarded through faith for a salvation ready to be
revealed in the last time. So he's saying, you've been born again.
You have a living hope because Christ is alive. But it's not just about today.
It's about something coming. And the fact that he is alive,
we're gonna sing this song later, and I just, I can't wait living hope, right?
We're gonna sing that song about Jesus who is alive and one day's coming back to
take us home with him. That's the hope.
And if you remember the,
the Colossian church was being squeezed by all these religions around
them, many of which would not even mention an afterlife at all.
It was all about just kind of getting your life right here.
And so the hope for the colossian Christians of something greater to
come would be a powerful witness in their culture.
That's what one Peter says later in chapter three. In your hearts, honor Christ,
the Lord as holy. That means honor him as Christ above all,
always being prepared to make a defense to anyone who asks you
for a reason, for the hope that is in you. Right?
So this is a witness. The fact that we can look at the future and say,
you know what? There's a hope coming. There's a certainty of hope coming.
It's faith that I can't see it,
but I still know it's there and there is hope that comes.
That's a massive witness when you face death,
when you face hard times.
But that's not just a witness. That same eternal hope is a powerful motivator
because in Colossians one,
verse five is how the word ties back to the statements in verse four.
I'm gonna read it again since we heard of your faith in Christ Jesus,
of the love you have for all the saints because of the hope laid up for you
in heaven. So our hope in Christ,
coming back one day is a powerful motivation for constant faith
and costly love. Even today,
like just think about it. If I have all that I need,
if I know that on the other side of death I have everything forever,
then then I can be steady. Today
I can sacrifice more willingly.
'cause I'm not holding on to this stuff because I got it all already coming.
See how this works, right?
There's a hope there that gives me different reactions today.
And those are the things that he talks about that spring from eternal hope.
He's seeing their faith in love. And so he says, your hope is why you do that.
And that's the results of hope.
And so notice what it leads to. Again, I'm gonna dig into those a little bit.
Eternal hope in Christ leads to faith in Christ. First,
this is verse four, right? He's he's saying I,
I can see this in you because of the hope you have.
You have faith in Christ Jesus.
Now, I'm sure you've heard about or read about in the news how that word faith
is often thrown around so flippantly as meaning any religious belief,
right? You've heard that people of all faiths.
And in some sense that's true because there's people who believe what they
believe. Of course they do believe those things. But notice in here,
Colossians one, Paul makes it very explicit. It's not just faith in anything.
It's faith in Christ Jesus, Faith.
And that word faith means not only which,
which we kind of waver back and forth when we talk about faith,
it's not just mentally agreeing to a set of facts about Jesus.
It's personal trust and commitment to Jesus.
But we can't forget that it actually is assenting agreeing to affirming a
set of beliefs about who Jesus is. You have to believe who Jesus is.
You have these exclusive claims of truth about Jesus.
We agree with yes, as part of faith.
And think about how countercultural that would've been in in Paul's day in
Colossae with all these mixed religions going that that they're saying any
different way is what you can believe. And that's okay.
Paul's saying that only faith in Jesus is the way to be good with God.
How countercultural that would be,
is that not counter-cultural today just as much, right?
Like
These exclusive claims that only through Christ can you be right
with God, right? No, no. We're told all over the place,
there's many ways to God.
You can believe whatever you want and you'll eventually get there.
We're worshiping the same God as those people over there, right?
And and any exclusive claims of truth, man,
we're stiff arming those really fast. Like we don't like to be told what to do.
But that's the nature of faith.
It does involve affirming the set of truths about who Jesus is,
that he is above all else, that he is the only way.
And then of course committing to him as a result of that, he's,
he's putting this in front of us, in front of the Colossian Christians saying,
guys, I've heard of your faith.
I've heard of your commitment to him.
But just like back then today, man,
our sinful nature kicks against that submission to Jesus as the
exclusive way as Jesus commanding our lives. I mean, we, we push back on that,
but, but think about how that can get a little bit easier
if we start with the eternal hope that's laid up for believers,
Right?
When you think about the fact that we've been given everything that I need for,
okay, I'm all yours, Jesus, you, you've given me everything. So, okay,
whatever you say,
Romans eight says that in this hope we were saved. Now,
hope that is seen is not hope for who hopes for what he sees.
But if we hope for what we do not see, we wait for it with patience.
I love that phrase. You can't see Jesus,
you can't see eternity with him. You can't see heaven.
We can't see those things, but we know 'cause Jesus resurrected, it's there,
but we wait for it with patience. We wait for it.
Committing to him in faith that he's got this under control,
that's what hope does, builds our faith.
Yet Paul also understood that that kind of hope fueled faith should then produce
something like in verse four,
we learned that their hope led to faith of course,
but their hope didn't just stop with like mentally agreeing with this.
Their hope led to a sacrificial love,
right? You see that here, that that your love,
not only for those that are just like them, not only for their, their buddies,
their hope led to a love that was sacrificial for all the
saints, For everybody who believed.
In fact, verse eight calls it a spirit filled love.
And if you know the Holy Spirit, you know that,
that he's not just a feeling like there's an action, there's an activity.
And if it's a spirit filled love, that means it's going to be active,
it's gonna be sacrificial soul.
And listen, if anything, if anything,
this spirit filled Jesus kind of agape love is what distinguishes
Christians from the rest of the world,
the absolute base level at minimum.
This is what distinguishes should distinguish that we sacrifice
for others good.
You think of the story of the Thessalonians in the New Testament,
impoverished really had nothing and they gave
sacrificially money to support the Macedonian church that was in desperate need.
Why? Because they love them as their brothers and sisters in Christ.
For all the saints, your love for all the saints,
it's an evidence of their love First John,
the whole book of first John verses or chapters three and four especially
says, here's how you know you are alive spiritually. You wanna know,
you wanna know the test. Do you love the brothers?
Do you love the brothers and sisters in the church? Do you love one another?
That's the true test because it models how Jesus loved us.
If he loved us like that, we can love one another like that.
But, but how does that relate to? And he says, okay, great.
We can love each other.
But how does that relate to this hope laid up for you in heaven in verse five?
Well, here's, here's how one Peter says it,
One Peter one 20 through 23 talking about Jesus,
that he was foreknown before the foundation of the world,
but he was made manifest in the last times,
visible in the last times for the sake of you.
Who through him are believers in God who raised him.
God raised him from the dead,
gave him glory so that your faith and hope are in God.
But this, watch this verse 22,
having purified your souls by your obedience to the truth for a sincere,
brotherly love, love one another,
earnestly from a pure heart since you've been born again,
not a perishable seed but of imperishable through the living abiding word of
God.
What that means is that if you have been made new
by God, through faith,
by hearing and believing this word of truth, the gospel, he says,
if that's true of you, you ought to be loving the brothers.
You ought to be loving the church.
You ought to be loving the brothers and sisters around you.
You ought to be loving like Christ because
he's made you different. He's made you new. It's evidence of your faith.
So again, you see, eternal hope leads to deeper faith in Christ.
It leads to loving others for Christ, Right? This,
this hope that's settled means you can be steady at work when you get
blasted for something or you can be,
you can be steady when you get that cancer diagnosis.
You can be steady when you face difficult times in in your home
and you can love sacrificially the brothers and sisters around you because of
the hope that's coming that you have everything you need already.
So there's a lot of hope.
But Paul then summarizes that entire word of hope with one word at the end of
verse five.
Look at the word he uses at the end of verse five in Colossians one.
It's the word of hope, the gospel.
Here's how he says, you wanna know what that word of hope is. It's the gospel
that they'd heard the good news. It's the word of hope. It's the word of truth.
And for Paul, it was important, not just because it was good news,
it was because of the truth it contains. That makes it good news.
See, the gospel to Paul is not merely an invitation.
You tack onto the end of a sermon.
It's not merely a technique for changing people's lives.
It's not what he says about the gospel. He says,
the gospel's actually a power that is let loose in the world because of who it's
about. Again,
he's opposing false claims all over colossae.
And instead of that he says, let's go back to the gospel.
Go back to the gospel,
go back to the truth that's found in one Corinthians chapter 15
verses one through four. I would remind you of the gospel I preach to you,
which you received in which you stand, and by which you're being saved.
If you hold fast to the word I preach to you, unless you believed in vain.
So this is the gospel that not only saves, it's what we stand in even today.
Verse three, for I delivered to you as a first importance. What I also received,
here's the gospel.
Basically that Christ died for our sins in accordance with the scriptures.
He was buried and he was raised on the third day in accordance with the
scriptures. That's what he goes back to.
He's, this is the most important message I can ever tell you is this truth,
that Jesus died and was resurrected.
No other religious system has a God who took on flesh,
lived the perfect life,
died a substitutionary death to pay for our sins,
and then defeated death to come outta that grave alive.
Like that truth,
the word of hope is what guarantees the hope stored up.
For those who believe that hope in heaven,
it's guaranteeing that because Christ isn't still dead,
he actually is alive.
This is why here we always sing the gospel.
We pray the gospel, we preach the gospel.
We call one another to believe the gospel and respond to the gospel like this is
all it is. Why? Because it is true.
It's the word of truth proven in Christ, in his resurrection,
and it is the word of hope that points us to something to come.
Paul wrote in Romans one 15 that even Christians need the gospel
regularly. All of us.
It's not just the entry point like the the ticket you give to the ticket
taker going into the concert, right?
That it's not just that it is actually what we need. The word of hope,
that's the constant drumbeat you get here.
The gospel pointing us to Christ above all, because we lead,
we believe that will lead us to hope, that will lead us to faith,
and that will lead us to sacrificial love.
Here's what's beautiful about this passage in Colossians. It doesn't stop there
Because then spilling out of Paul's mouth are words regarding the
power of that gospel.
He almost personifies it. In verse six, he says,
it has come to you like the gospel, got legs and ran to colossal. No, no.
It was through Eris, right?
We know this local boy who came to Christ and Paul sent him back to preach the
gospel in his hometown. This beloved servant, faithful minister.
He loved them. He was loved. This is a apris,
an example really we could all follow.
Whether you leave Edmund or not be a minister of the gospel where you are,
but Paul said the gospels come to you.
It's power not just personified. He imagined it then like a plant.
This is so interesting. Look at verse six. He says,
the gospels come to you as indeed in the whole world.
It is bearing fruit and increasing as it also does among you
since the day you heard it and understood the grace of God in truth.
So he's now not just a person, it's a plant. Well, we know it's not a plant,
but, but notice what he's doing.
He reminds them here that the gospel was at work among them,
it was bearing fruit. It was increasing in their own lives.
The gospel was at work. It's just like in Galatians five,
he talks about the fruit of the spirit showing up,
that God's changing you. Or John 15,
Jesus said he appointed all believers to bear fruit like this is
showing something different. Or Mark four,
the parable Jesus gave where the good soil received,
the gospel seed produced fruit 30 fold, 60 fold, a hundred fold.
Something happens when the gospel takes root.
What this means is that the colossian Christians should take heart in the fact
that the gospel really was working in their lives. Paul's an objective,
outsider, looks at colossae. He says, Hey guys, I can see it
like I can see it.
Riss even was praying for this, that that the church, this is in chapter four,
that the church would stand, mature and fully assured in the will of God.
Paul and Riss were praying that the church would grow because of the gospel,
Because
Why? Why would they need to hear this? Maybe they couldn't see it themselves.
Maybe. Maybe they were a little bit blinded by these other religious systems.
It was drowning out the fact that God really was at work in their life and they
could not see it. That they needed to hear again.
That gospel was at work among them.
Maybe they were confused by all the religious experiences that everybody else
was having around them, and it sure seemed like, man,
what we're experiencing is not like what they,
they're a little bit crazy over there.
They're doing some weird stuff over there, man.
Mine doesn't look like what they seem to look like. You know, Paul says,
Hey guys, remember what God, what God has done,
and listen, that's the thing about experiences. It can mislead you either way.
An experience can mislead you from the truth, but,
but a lack of experience can also mislead you that you don't have something just
because you're not experiencing what they have. Listen,
the reality is God was making them each more like Jesus,
and sometimes that takes a really long time. In fact,
it takes all of us our whole lives, But,
but you might not be able to see it every day or week,
but you look back a couple years and you say, oh, that that's the way I was.
Now look at the way God made me to be and and even collectively,
he's looking at the church saying, guys, look,
you're way more loving together than you were before. Don't miss it.
It's not crazy fanciful stuff like they're experiencing,
but notice it's working in you. God is working in you.
Listen,
I know you might not feel like it right now. Church.
You don't have the same conversion experience like this guy over over here or
that lady over there. You grew up in the church.
You don't really know a time you didn't know Jesus,
but you know you love him and committed to him.
Your journey to Christ is very different than everybody else's. That's okay.
Has God worked in your life? That's the question.
Like can you attribute change in your life to God doing something
or just 'cause you're in a better situation than you were before that,
that that's not what we're talking about. We're talking about God's work.
I just met with a man this week
who shared how deeply God had broken him and he'd been a believer
in his mind his whole life, but just the last couple years, his pride,
his control,
God had crushed him in some big ways and now though
now he lives free.
He's free to live a life that just follows Jesus and is honest and open.
How encouraged it was for me, how encouraging it was to hear this truth
and so God is at work in your life.
Can you attribute anything in your life to what God has done? Look for it.
Look way back and see what God has done and then submit to his
work continued today 'cause you're not finished.
But also he was talking to the church in Colossae are,
are we church becoming more gentle,
becoming more servant minded, kinder,
more generous as a church where we're giving away?
'cause the gospel's not just gonna work in us individually.
The gospel's gonna work in us together as a whole as well.
And so the God of salvation was working in their lives.
But also notice this growing plant was so powerful that it was going beyond
Colossae. It was going to all parts of the earth.
He says this hope was spreading beyond just
their church. Why?
This missional spread of hope was spreading because it was
empowered. This is the truth.
The spread of hope in your life, in our lives,
in the world is empowered by God. Because remember,
it's God who causes the growth of the gospel in us.
It's God who sins and plants it elsewhere.
Now, does he use us? Yes, he does.
In light of the hope he's given us like we should work hard to plant and sow and
water the gospel seed, but we cannot forget this is God's work.
Gospel work is God's work.
It is interesting that some people believe this phrase in verse six,
that he uses bearing fruit and increasing that phrase is a callback to Genesis
one and two, that narrative where God creates everything.
'cause remember what happened then remember,
it was God's word that was creating and commanding,
and then through Adam, he called to multiply and fill the earth.
Check this out here in Colossians one,
it's the word of truth,
God's word that recreates and commands through
the new Adam Jesus to multiply and fill the earth.
Right? You see that like he's still called. That's still what he wants,
is that multiplication. Matthew 28, go make disciples of all nations.
Even in Acts 1224, the same phrase is used.
The word of God increased and multiplied like
this is a thread. From the very beginning. God was like, I want worshipers.
What I intended in the beginning through Christ now through us,
is that God fills the earth with his glory through redeemed humanity.
Adam and Eve were supposed to start that way, fill the earth with worshipers.
It failed. Now, through Christ,
he's filling the earth with worshipers through us on mission,
a redeemed humanity. Here's what that means.
As you and I hear the word of truth,
the gospel we're filled with hope. Leading to faith and love.
God's plan from the beginning is more and more fulfilled. That we are,
we are filling the earth as we live sin, we multiply the gospel.
We are filling the earth with worshipers that he intended from the beginning,
and here's what happens as a result. Here's the the end game of this,
a global eternal kingdom society that
lives, thinks, acts loves like Jesus.
That's the new kingdom. One day we'll be fully inaugurated.
For now, we are just multiplying, multiplying,
multiplying as we live sent, And so if you wonder, that's why we're here.
That's why God still left us here. He didn't just poof us when we got saved,
right? He, he left us here. Why did he leave us for this?
That's why we gather together to be reminded of these truths so we can go
multiply.
That's why we love one another like we do because it's an image of the kingdom
to come. That's why we go and carry that gospel.
That's why all of this happens is because God wants his glory to shine through
his people
and that should be for us, a grateful response
where our lips are full of Thanksgiving.
Why? Because Christ has saved us that,
that he is above all holy, righteous,
but he has saved us, so what else would we do
but give our lives to him? That's why
we preach the gospel. That's why Paul reminds him.
It's because of the gratitude we have for all that he's done for us,
and praise God for that. Praise God for the hope that we have.